I heard that I was i learning how to
code as part of my graduate research as
I came to grad schools experimentalist
and I learned some scripting to process
my data and and so I started learning
Python by way of a couple of EDX and
Coursera courses but it wasn't until my
second year of graduate school or
something that I wrote my first for loop
so I really had no experience with
programming until then and so I'm
curious to know a little bit about
backgrounds of the people in the room
is there anybody think here that doesn't
have much experience with with Python
that came to PI data because they wanted
to learn about Python but aren't really
using it yet or okay so everybody here
is a solid Python user it looks like
okay are there other languages here that
are amongst the people room are there
other languages that you're using
regularly other than Python like are
there you know our users or okay MATLAB
users what about lower level languages
like Fortran or C okay some of you all
right and over the people in the room
who here is a physical scientist all
right engineer and I guess a data
scientist broadly but all right let's
see computer scientists what about
people in social sciences and if you
didn't raise your hand you already call
out what what are you studying or
researching or working in
oh okay so anyone else in finance but a
popular okay all right great well thank
you for for coming today to learn a
little bit about Julia I'm gonna start
by doing a quick intro so we have a
sense of what Julia is and why we might
be interested in learning Julia and and
after that we'll hop into the tutorial
materials themselves and so I'll start
by going over you know why we might want
to learn another language why Julia is
getting has been developed in the first
place
then we'll talk about an application of
Julia and see what it's like before
going on to Julia box where we have
Jupiter notebooks with all of our
material so this first question of you
know why do we want another language
here I have a periodic table of
languages where we have a bunch of
different programming pages organized
together and color-coded by the features
or the characteristics that they have
and so the natural question that is you
know with all these programming
languages out there all bringing
different things to the table why did
the create of Julia and you know broadly
the open source community developing
Julia and the ecosystem decide that it
was a worthwhile project what does Julia
bring to the table that we don't already
have with the existing languages out
there and the idea is that even with all
the different tools that are out there
we still something called the two
language problem and so I'll define a
bit what this two language problem is it
it comes from the idea that
traditionally languages are either
performant or productive where on the
one hand you know we have these
lower-level languages like Fortran and C
that allow us to write in a really
efficient code but if we want to be
efficient as programmers and you know be
able to do our work productively it's
often easier to work in a higher-level
language like you know Python or MATLAB
but the trade-off that were faced with
isn't truly just a trade-off between
performance and productivity because we
also have to consider generality so if
you're working with you know just a
special library or a domain-specific
language you know tool like no numpy for
example will allow you to get really
great performance and also be able to
work in like a high level environment
but then the scope of the tool that
you're working with will be limited so
this is really the trade-off
that were faced with performance
productivity versus trip generality and
the classical workaround is you know if
you if you need all of these things if
you want to work in a general-purpose
language that is both really fast and
easy to use people will will work with
two different languages well there start
with you know a language that they can
prototype in a language like Python or
MATLAB and once they get to a point
where they really need their
combinations to hit scale to do
something at production level they'll
then switch to a lower level language
like C or Fortran so they have work
different languages to get all of their
work done which introduces this you know
obvious redundancy and extra work in
their workflow and so this is the reason
that julia has been developed the idea
is or rather that the tagline for julia
is it looks like python feels like list
and runs like C or Fortran and I'll talk
you through what what we mean when we go
and when we make these claims the idea
though is that you know julia offers
productivity generality and performance
and so we can talk about Julia's
performance first so one of the the
notebooks that we'll do as part of the
tutorial is a notebook where we'll
benchmark different implementations of
the some function where some function is
just taking some vector that we can call
a and it's adding together all the
different elements of that vector and
for the purpose of benchmarking when we
look at how fast this operation runs in
Python and C and Julia side-by-side for
the purpose of benchmarking believes a
10 million element vector and see how
long that calculation takes to run and
so if we're just talking about you know
using the same you know simple algorithm
with their own notation of summing
things together and see we can do this
operation with the 10 million element
vector in about 10 milliseconds it takes
you no more than an order of magnitude
lakh when we go to python with you know
handwritten code if we do a handwritten
implication in Julia we get back down to
order a 10 milliseconds so we're
approaching a c-suites
there and the next thing that we say
that julia offers is productivity and if
you look at the implementations of our
sum function and
and Julius side-by-side what we see is
that they're really not that different
so I've put in the the actual
differences in our code here where it's
basically between a colon and a couple
different required keywords where you
have death and the colon and the Python
side and then you know the function and
the end keywords and the Julia side but
you know otherwise we can express
ourselves in the same high level manner
and it was really it was this sort of
difference between Python and Julia code
that got me really motivated to start
learning Julia coming for a Python
background and and at some point I I had
a friend who had been really excited
about Julia he had been using previously
MATLAB and C and switching off back and
forth between the two languages he he
went to Julia who was really excited
with the language and at some point in
expressing his enthusiasm to me Python
and then translated it to Julia and and
like the syntactic jeans that he
actually had to make in order to convert
my code to Julia were really minor but
he got more than an order of magnitude
speed improvement and the thing that I
had written so that was what got me
really excited about about learning
Julia cuz I felt like you know I
wouldn't have to make that many changes
to the way that I wrote code but that I
would still be able to get a speed bump
and I was starting to hit a bottleneck
and so my computations that was why I
started learning a second language and
then this third thing that we said that
Julia offers is generality and and this
is what we mean when we say that working
in Julia feels like working in a lisp
because Julia offers meta programming
facilities allow you to program with
macros for example the design paradigm
of Julia is multiple dispatch and the
fact that julia is generally a you know
general and an expressive language is
what ali written in julia itself one of
the things that's really cool about the
fact that julia is mostly written julie
itself is that this really starts to
tell blur the line between users and
developers of the language so a lot of
our most important developers of the
language are the people who came often
as graduate students and users to the
language and then found that they wanted
to start you know making contributions
because they wanted to tweak things to
work better for their purposes
and the idea is that because you know
Julia is Julia when you start to look
under the hood there's not this extra
barrier to to looking under the hood and
starting to me so the application of
Julia that I always like to talk about
is the Celeste research project
so the Celeste project took data from
the Sloan Digital Sky Survey which was
an effort to collect data on I think 35
percent of the visible sky and so you
know they they over the course of this
survey gathered about 178 terabytes of
data so it was a pretty huge data set
and since this is PI data so I probably
don't need to how large 178 terabytes is
and they're probably several of you
working with even larger data sets but
to give a sense of scale because I'm I
like to help myself visualize scale here
this is you know 10 to the 14 bytes
order of 25,000 DVDs worth of data and a
really silly statistic that I like to
include is that if you wanted to print a
dataset this large on written paper it
take you hundreds of thousands of
pick-up trucks to carry that that paper
but the point is there was this big data
set lying around in the first you know
10 or so years that it was an existence
there wasn't a whole lot done with it or
it wasn't treated systematically but
then this team of researchers came
together to form the Celeste research
team and what they did was that they
catalogued 188 mil stars and galaxies
from this database and they did that
using julia to write all of their
software and then nursed supercomputers
of it Lawrence Berkeley National Lab in
the Bay Area to run all of their julia
code now the thing that's that's cool
about this besides the fact that you
know they were able to do a project of
this scale and doing this huge
cataloguing is that the entire
calculation that generated this catalog
took on again this was you know using
using huge machines up at nurse where
they were able to break the petaflop
barrier so this made Julia the third
language to join the club after seeing
Fortran and and to do this whole
calculation they used over a million
threads or 9,000 nodes
so gives us a sense of Julie's ability
to to distribute and so so the next
question then is like why was Julie
importance on the Celeste project this
les project looked like if you know some
other tool or set of tools had been used
and maybe the the first natural answer
to that question is like well if if
Julie hadn't been the language of choice
then maybe there would have been two
different languages used and they would
have needed to be some you know
trade-off between working in Python and
then you know moving moving to C and
that's true and that you know there was
this sort of natural otherwise been some
sort of natural you know inefficiency I
guess they need to to recode things from
from Python to C for example but really
the impact you think of using Julie on
this problem was more profound than that
because what it did was that in bringing
together this huge team of researchers
who came from very different backgrounds
some were physical scientists and others
were statisticians and others were
computer scientists it allowed everybody
to work in the same code base from the
beginning so the way that the two
language problem often looks when you're
working in an environment with you know
people from various backgrounds is that
you know the the physical scientists
will be the ones or you know generally
the domain experts will be the ones to
do that first prototyping in a
high-level language it's normally only
when they're done that they'll then pass
the baton off to the computer scientist
or HPC specialists who will you know
translation to lower-level code and so
instead the fact that everybody was
working name code based from the
beginning meant that you know the team
was able to iterate more rapidly and
really work together as you know both
the science and the implementation of
the science evolved together so with
that these are just some examples of
places where Julia's getting used in
industry outside celeste was largely an
academic project though there were some
companies involved but it's being used
both in academia and industry and we're
seeing you know uptake of the language
especially after the 1.0 released a
couple months ago at the end of the
summer and after this tutorial if you're
interested in
joining any of our our online
communities we'd be happy to have only
people there happy to answer questions
and I can put this slide up later to or
work give you these links my email
there's at the bottom and yeah both both
slack and discourse are great places to
ask general questions and of course get
out if you have you know issues to file
all different places where you can get
involved so now we can jump into the
tutorial and if you want to run along on
Julia box you can log in here I'm not
sure if have people tried being in yet -
Julia box to see if ok alright cool yeah
so with email github Google or LinkedIn
you'll be able to get in there now once
you're on Julia box once you're on Julia
box you'll see a tutorials subdirectory
let me see if I can pull that up quickly
okay so you hit launch once you're in
there
I'm gonna be working on a local copy for
mine but once you're on Julia Box you
should be able to go into tutorials and
then introductory materials and then
inside introductory materials is intro
to Julia which is where I'll be working
are people able to get onto Julia box if
you're trying yeah is anybody having any
issues okay
alright so once you are and did
everybody hear where they needed to go
once they were logged in we're all
uninsured - Julia okay fantastic alright
so once you're inside intro to Julia we
have a series of numbered notebooks and
the first notebook is just to show you
what it's like to work in a Jupiter
notebook and who's familiar with Jupiter
notebooks many of you use them okay for
those of you that haven't we'll just do
a quick rundown when we're in this
environment you can add additional cells
with this plus sign and by default you
can write code in any of these cells and
then execute that code so you know we
could just add for example there by
default whenever you execute a cell
which you can do by hitting run in the
arrow with the arrow up there by going
to cell and then clicking run cells for
example or by selecting the cell and
hitting Shift + Enter
so when you run a cell by default just
the very last line of the cell will
print to standard out if you want to
suppress that output you can add a
semicolon thereafter and then it looks
like nothing happened and then a couple
like Julia environment specific things
both when we're in a Jupiter notebook
like this and when we're at the repple
if we proceed any function call with a
question mark
we're actually entering the the help
mode that allows us to pull up
documentation so whenever you see a
function that you're not familiar with
you can just put a question mark before
it and then you'll get the docs and also
you can enter shell mode from both
Julia ruffle or the Jupiter notebook if
you're working in a colonel and you can
do that by putting a semicolon before
any shell commands
so if we say semicolon LS we can see for
example all of the documents that are
stored in my current folder okay so any
questions about navigating this notebook
interface Julia box is slow yeah okay
they might be pulling up more notes that
sometimes an issue when a couple people
sign is it slow like loading and open a
new notebook oh okay
all right
and once you have a notebook open does
it run easily through the notebook or is
that also slow okay
all right well I hope it picks up and if
it doesn't if you yeah I'll demo insofar
as I need to I suppose
okay so the first the notebooks one
through six are really meant to be sort
of a whirl with four of giulia syntax
and a lot of I think will look pretty
familiar if you're you know coming from
a Python background and then after that
we have some notebooks on you know
showing you how to pull in packages from
the Julia ecosystem and a speed demo or
a benchmarking demo as well as we can
talk about linear algebra at the end and
the design paradigm if those are of
interest depending on how much time we I
think we can go pretty quickly through a
lot of this in tax since it should look
familiar but we'll see I'll see how it
goes
so notebook one getting started the
purpose of this notebook is just to show
you how to how to print in Julia how to
assign variables how to comment and what
our syntax our basic math looks like so
first off if you want to print we like
to use this print outline function which
is going to add a an extra line whenever
you print it's a print line and you can
throw you know for example strings or
other variable types inside that
function call when we assign variables
in julia julia is dynamic and so we
don't need to declare you know but for
example of our variables up front so I
can just say my answer equals 42 and
then when I ask Julia with this function
type of what the type of that variable
is Julia can tell that's an n64
similarly we can see that my PI is a
float 64 and this emoji smiley cat that
I assigned to the string smiley cat is a
string and if you if you want to
actually create your own
emojis or you'll pull up your own emojis
use this tab completion where you'll put
a backslash and then a colon and then
hit tab and be able to select the emoji
from there so SMI should start to
trigger the smiley cat yeah you can and
one thing that will show at the end of
this for example like if I it's just
well I think I could do
I said convert for example if I if I
started with something that was for
example uh I maybe I'm not sure the
integer that I first declared wasn't in
32 or 964 I could say something like and
then if I were to interrogate what the
type of a is yeah so I can convert
different types like that
okay other questions so far
okay another thing is that you know once
we've assigned a value to a value of a
given type to a variable we can reassign
that variable to a different value of a
different type without any issue so
smiley cat emoji used to be a string and
here if I assign it to an integer
there's no issue now smiley cat is an
integer and and also programming with
emojis is a good example of Giulia being
generic in general so here we have this
smiling emoji in sad emoji equal to 0
negative 1 and now we can create boolean
statements from emojis like this where
smiley cat plus round face turns us into
a happy face commenting in Giulia just
like in Python we can leave single line
comments with a hashtag or a pound sign
and we can create multi-line comments by
sandwiching our comments inside two
pound signs and and two equal signs and
then the syntax for basic math will look
pretty familiar the only real difference
coming from Python is that if you want
to exponentiate something you have to
use the caret operator rather than a
double star okay so that's it for the
first notebook and then our second
notebook is on strings in Julian so
we'll talk about how to create a string
how to interpolate strings and then how
to concatenate them so first off to
create a string we have two different
ways in julia both using the double
quotation signs we can either use a
single set of double quotation signs or
a triple set of double quotation marks
and one of the differences between these
two different types of strings is that I
can add a bunch of formatting to the
second type where we have the three sets
and Julia understands then that you know
I like for example was trying to include
these newline characters in my string
another difference is that I can quote
inside the second type of string but not
the first
so it's ambiguous where
string actually end this first case but
when we have the three sets of double
quotation marks defining the beginning
and end of the string we can throw
quotation marks inside the string
without ambiguity now unlike in Python
single quotation marks does not give us
a string so here letter a is a char or a
character and if we try to enclose many
characters inside single quotation marks
we'll get an error so we only get one
character inside inside single quotation
marks now to interpolate strings in
Julia here I'll create some variables to
interpolate we will throw dollar signs
next to the names of the variables that
we want to include in our string so here
I'm throwing the variable name by dollar
sign name and here numb fingers is
preceded by dollars sign and numb toes
is posted by a dollar sign in this
example here we see that we can
interpolate expressions that will get
evaluated and then thrown inside the
string so here we're 10 and 10 together
to interpolate the number 20 so there we
just throw parentheses around the
expression that we want to interpolate
and then the dollar sign goes that pair
of parentheses and we also have a few
different ways we can do string
concatenation did you have a question or
no okay I'm just checking Kay all right
so string concatenation so here I have
these two short strings s3 and s4 and
then we have this my l'académie assigned
to the number 10 there and so if I
wanted to concatenate the strings s3 and
s4 together I could use this string
function and string takes arbitrary
numbers of inputs and the inputs don't
have to be you know just other strings
they can be whatever you like really so
if I call string here on three inputs
now I get to my first concatenated
string how many cats is to many cats
which is I don't know but 10 is too few
and we could have concatenated those
strings s3 and s4 together instead using
the star operator so this is another
difference with with Python we can't
add we can't add two strings together
with the plus operator we have to use
star and the reason for that a commonly
asked question is that you know addition
by definition is is you know commutative
and when we're adding our strings
together we don't intend to be
commutative whereas multiplication in
general is not commutative when you
think about like matrices being
multiplied by vectors and that sort of
thing so those sort of the design
philosophy that went into the
multiplication operator being something
that allows you to concatenate rather
than the addition operator and when you
exponentiate things in julia the star
operator is what's really getting called
under the hood and so because the star
operator allows us to concatenate
strings if I were to exponentiate a
string I will get large or I can get
large repetition of the string that way
are there any questions on those string
intro
uh yeah look if I just said times 10
like this yeah so that one doesn't have
a method defined but if you wanted it to
do something you could define a method
for yourself other questions okay
so the third notebook then is on data
structures and we can talk through what
making tuples dictionaries and arrays
look like in Julia so first off tuples
look just the same as they do in in
Python we enclose our our data that we
want to enclose in a tuple inside
parentheses so here we're creating this
tuple called my favorite animals and
first thing to note here is that Julia
is one indexed rather than 0 index so
when I asked for the first element of
this tuple I'm getting penguins rather
than cats and and because tuples are
immutable we can't update them penguins
will forever be that that first element
in our tuple we can't update to otters
as of julia 1.0 we now have something
called named tuples in the base language
the idea of a named tuple is that we can
assign variables within the tuple to the
elements of that tuple so for example I
could say you know within this tuple my
favorite animals that I'm creating I'm
going to have some field assigned a bird
variable some field assigned to a mammal
and another to a marsupial so when I
create this version of my favorite
animals
I can still index in to grab that first
element which is penguins or I could
grab penguins by saying like what is the
bird the bird variable inside of that
I'm actually I'm not sure to create a
dictionary in Julia we can use this this
dict function call so capital D ICT and
we can just call that with empty
parentheses following it we can
initialize our dictionary to have key
value pairs at the start and if we want
to initialize it with key value pairs we
use the syntax that shown here where
will well type out our first key and
then create an arrow with an equal sign
and a right pointing Arrowhead and then
the name of the value associated with
that key so for example create a
dictionary like my phone book here where
we're calling dick and then adding
values that our phone numbers sort of
strings associated with names that are
stored into strings so now if we wanted
to perform a I'll look up in a
dictionary like this we can put the name
of the dictionary followed by square
brackets and then and then me the key in
there and adding additional entries to
our existing dictionary we can do just
like this where we're using that same
indexing syntax on the left and then an
equal sign and the new value on the
right to check that that worked if we
call my phone book we see that we're up
to three entries now we can use this
function called pop bang if we want to
remove an existing entry from a
dictionary and so we did here is that we
called pop bang so pop with an excellent
point following it on the name of the
dictionary and then the key from the key
value pair that we want to remove so
that returns the value and and then we
can see that Kramer's been deleted from
my phonebook
we can't index into dictionaries just
like just like in Python you can't index
into no okay all right just checking I
forgot that one and so if we if we try
to you know throw a one inside square
brackets for a lookup Julia thinks that
we're looking for some key called one
and that's why we're getting a method or
it's a key error there and finally to
make arrays the syntax we use looks like
making a list in Python so we're closing
our elements now inside square brackets
and one of the things that we see here
when we create this array this sort of
signature that we're getting back says
that we have created something that has
five elements and it's telling us that
this is an array that is 1d where the
elements of that 1d array are strings
similarly if we were to create for
example this array called Fibonacci we
can see that this is a 1d array that
contains in 64's but there's no issue
with creating arrays that have many
types inside of them so here this array
called mixture it's a 1d array that now
takes elements of the any type where if
you were to look at the type hierarchy
for for julia and any is an abstract
type that encompasses all other types
within the language so if we want to you
know index into an array and grab
elements it looks just like in python so
here we're grabbing the third element of
my friends here we're updating that
third element to Baby Bop and otherwise
we can edit or update an array using the
push bang and the pop bang functions
just the way that you would in Python
except that here we have these
exclamation points at the end and we'll
talk about in a later notebook why we
have exclamation points there but for
now push bang with throw 21 onto the end
of the array called Fibonacci and pop
bang would return whatever's at the end
so there's removing the 21 and taking us
back down to that seven element array
they're questions so far yes I imagine
it's lower since they're not stack
allocated but well I actually don't even
if that's a good I'm not sure I I
thought that they were slower but I'm
not yeah okay thanks so all of the
examples I've given so far have been of
you know 1d data structures or rather a
raise of sorry if not just a raise but
generally I've shown data structures
that have contained scalars as their
their values but you know we can create
data structures of other data structures
so for example I could create an array
of arrays here I've created an array of
an array of strings and that's what this
is saying here it looks a little cryptic
at first but we we have a difference in
julia there's a difference between a 1d
array that contains other 1d arrays
that's not the same as a 2d array that
would be like a matrix so vectors of
vectors are separate from matrices and I
just used a bunch of different terms at
once but in in Julia a 1d array is also
called a vector a 2d array is also
called a matrix and so here what this is
telling us is that we have a 1d array
where now the elements of this 1d array
our other 1d arrays that contain strings
or we could say it's a vector a vector
of strings here numbers if we look at
this part here this is a good thing that
we have a 1d array that contains 1d
arrays of integers or it's a vector a
vector of integers one function that
generates multi-dimensional arrays is
this Rand function where by default Rand
is generating an array that has
the dimensions of the arguments that are
passed to it so if we say Randolph four
and three we're getting a four by three
array and then it randomly populates
that array that it creates with numbers
between 0 & 1
and so we can see here that the
dimensionality of this array that we
just created is 2 so we have a 2d array
of floats and here we have a 3d array of
floats and the last thing to say about
arrays here is just to be careful when
you're trying to copy them so you know
if if you for example started with this
array called Fibonacci that we've
already seen and then you try to copy it
by simply adding or rather assigning the
array some numbers to it what you'll see
is that if you were to you know update
the array called some numbers by
indexing into it and then check out
Fibonacci thereafter Fibonacci has also
been updated because all we did was give
a seconding to an existing data
structure so you need to use the copy
function or the deep copy function if
you want to actually copy an array where
deep copy performs recursive copies and
that's what I show here I restore
Fibonacci to its original state
I copy Fibonacci to get this new array
called some more numbers and then you
know when you perform updates on some
more numbers Fibonacci remains untouched
so any questions on giulia data
structures okay great so we're halfway
through the the whirlwind some text tour
okay so while in for loops in Giulia and
these will look very familiar the the
big differences that you'll see or our
while loop syntax is that we have an end
keyword to delineate when our our
control flow ends we don't need a colon
after the wild statement and it also
doesn't really matter it doesn't it
doesn't matter what kind of whitespace
you use to indent so here I've used
about four spaces I think but if I
wanted to add you know arbitrary numbers
of spaces and this while loop where I'm
counting to ten would work just the same
way
and then a four loop is going to look
pretty similar where again now we have
our four keyword our in keyword we have
an end keyword just as with a while loop
no : after the line with the four and
[Music]
another thing to note here is I'm using
a range in Julia to count from one to
ten inside this four loop so ranges we
can create in Julia by specifying the
beginning of the range a colon than the
end of a range and if I want to add a
step I would add that in between the
beginning in the end
with again colons to separate each of
those those numbers so they are get
printing all the odd numbers in my for
loop and just as you know you could do
in Python we could it could iterate over
collections generally so arrays or or
ranges or or whatever you might like and
so the next part I wanted to show a
couple different ways to do something to
show you some syntactic sugar in Julia
so there's something that we're going to
do is to create an addition table where
that addition table is a matrix where
the entry of every matrix is going to be
the sum of the row and the column
indices of that element so we'll start
by initializing or creating a matrix of
zeros and to do that I'm using this fill
command in Julia where the fill command
takes as the first input whatever you
want to fill the array that you're
creating with and then as the second
input you can pass a tuple that
specifies the dimensions of the array
that you're creating and filling so we
have another matrix of zeros called a
and if we wanted to create our addition
table we could do that by creating a
nested for loop that looks like this
where we iterate over all the rows all
of the columns and then we're indexing
into our multi-dimensional array a there
and updating each of its entries now if
we wanted to we could use some syntactic
sugar where we condense our four loops
onto the same line and only use you know
one for keyword and one end keyword here
so what that looks like is shown here
and I'm creating a matrix B so we'll do
the same thing to B that we did to a
with this condensed for-loop syntax
where now you can see that we're taking
i from 1 to m and j from 1 to n on the
same line we just have a comma there to
separate the two different iterators so
we get the same result in the end and
the third way that we might have done
this is by doing an array comprehension
which looks just like a list
comprehension so an array comprehension
in Julia would look like this where
we've basically taken what was the first
line there what I have highlighted is
the first line of this condensed for
loop here and then we've pasted inside
of our square brackets and to the left
of our for statement we have effectively
our loop body or what we want to
populate the entries of the array that
we're creating with our list
comprehensions familiar to people here
or yeah okay all right and in just in
case there's anyone that maybe hasn't
seen lists or array comprehensions
before the idea is that in one day for
example I could do something like X for
X in one to ten and then I'm basically
looping over all the the indices of the
array that I want to create so in 1d
this is what an array comprehension
would look like I'm sorry does it work
for what it does yeah we can we can
declare an anonymous functions yeah
questions on on loops so far
all right notebook five then is on
conditional statements in Julia's so in
Julia we have our our if and our LS
keywords instead of Elif we have else if
and we end our conditional statements
with an end so the first example that I
have here of actually implementing some
sort of conditional is my implementation
of the the fizzbuzz test in julia has
anybody heard of fizzbuzz before okay so
so we have the idea of the fizzbuzz test
is that yeah you might in going in for a
programming interview be given a
question where you you're given a number
or a set of numbers and if the number is
divisible by three you want to print
fizz if it was y5 you want to print buzz
and if it's divisible by both fizz or by
post three and five then you want to
print fizz buzz and so here I'll I like
the number 42 so and it's 42 and then
what we're doing here is checking for
Doozers of white divisibility by both 3
& 5 and I'm doing that with this double
ampersand to say and alternatively I
could have just said a single ampersand
but I'll talk to you about the
difference at the end of this notebook
but yeah a single ampersand will say and
I'm using this double equal sign to
check equality and then we have the
modulo operator and and otherwise our if
else if and else and end keywords so if
we do that we get fizz ternary operators
are another way to express conditionals
in Julia that I had never seen as a
Python user so I think they're kind of
cool the idea is that if you if you have
a conditional statement that it's
basically if a b LC end you could
rewrite that conditional statement to be
a question mark be : c and so i'll show
you now what i mean by that so we could
have say say we have two numbers x and y
and I'll sign them two three and four
and if we want to return the larger of
the two numbers we might write a
conditional statement like this where we
see if where we say if X is greater than
Y X else Y and we could rewrite this
conditional statement using a ternary
operator as I've done right here so now
we have our conditional statement just
copied from up here and then we throw a
question mark after that and then
whatever would normally come if that's
true followed by a colon and then
whatever would come up that's false and
what comes you know after the colon
could be another such ternary operator
and you could sort of string them
together and create something kind of
horrifying or exciting depending on your
perspective the final thing that I
wanted to talk about when we're talking
about conditional evaluation is a
short-circuit evaluation in julia and so
the idea is that in julia if if we by
default just say i'm going to add an
extra cell here but if i if i just say
i'll say false and true for example this
is going to return false but if i used
just a single ampersand to ask if both
false and true are true and then what
will happen is that julia will eagerly
evaluate this expression or rather julia
will look at this second argument to see
if it's true or false even after it's
already hit the false or even after it's
already seen enough to know that the
final answer should be should be false
similarly if we were if we were
short-circuiting and saying you know
true or sorry vertical line is how we
say or in julia so if i said true or
false the answer should be true and
we'll get that but we're actually going
to spend the time looking at false after
after seeing the first true and so if
you want to short-circuit that process
and only look at you know the minimum
amount of information that you need to
evaluate an expression you can
short-circuit by doubling your ampersand
or doubling your your vertical line and
so you'll get the same output in both of
these cases but if you get to the point
where you know a statement is already
going to be true or false you can just
stop checking and evaluating at that
point what would you not want to for I
know for bitwise operations this is the
default the default behavior is to not
short-circuit yeah that's I and I I
don't really understand honestly yeah I
don't know much about yeah don't wise
operations well that's that's the
default answer I've always been given
and I've never dug enough to understand
it does yeah it's more efficient other
questions so far okay and just to give
you in case it wasn't fully clear to
give you an example of where behavior we
can actually see behavior being
different in these statements we have
two short-circuiting statements one with
false and print high and then the second
is true and print high and we only
actually get to the point where we print
high in the second example because here
we we terminate our evaluation after we
see this first false so yeah and
similarly here if we if we short circuit
with or we only actually print the high
in the in the second case where we're
still looking for a true that the value
okay so our last note book on syntax is
notebook 6 which is on declaring
functions in Julia
so in this notebook we'll talk about how
to declare a function and we'll talk
about duck typing and Julia and then
mutating versus non retain functions and
we'll discuss a couple higher-order
functions at the end and I'll define
what a higher-order function is if
that's a foreign term
as the first half declaring a function
there are a few different ways that we
can declare a function in Julia the
first is to use the the function keyword
and the end keyword to delineate when
we're at the end of the function we put
the function name and the function
arguments on the same line as the
function keyword just like if we were
using death in Python again we don't
need any colon to say and on the same
line as the function keyword and we can
put our function body between the
function in the end or the lines with
the function in the end keywords and one
thing that you'll notice here is that
you know in this function f for example
where I'm squaring and in both of them
really I don't have any return statement
gulia by default is going to return
whatever is on the last line of the
function and I can choose to explicitly
say return if I want to and it won't
change anything about the way the
function is implemented under the hood
that's just a syntactic choice that I
can make is the programmer we can call
either of those functions just like you
would in Python so here where we're
greeting c3po and squaring 42 and now we
could have written either of these
functions with different syntax using
neither the function or the the end
keyword if we had just written the
function name the function input
arguments and then follow that with an
equal sign followed by the function body
on the right so there's our our second
version would say hi and our second
version of F and calling functions
written in this way is exactly the same
as calling them when they're declared in
the first way and the final way that we
might have declared
either of these functions is by writing
them as anonymous functions so if you're
not familiar with anonymous or lambda
functions and the idea is that you know
we could have a function that literally
has no name and so for example if I if I
declare this I've now declared a limit
of function where it is taking whatever
the input arguments are on the the
leftmost side and then sort of mapping
them to my function body on the right
where we have an arrow to separate the
input arguments and the the function
body but of course if we define a
function in this way without giving it
any name there's no way to access it
after we've created it and so we do have
the OP
if you like this syntax but you want to
be able to reference your function
thereafter you can bind a variable to
you our anonymous function like this so
here I'm binding the variable f3 to this
function that takes X and square is it
and then calling either of these
anonymous functions looks the same or we
have the same syntax for calling them as
we would for functions declared by the
either of the two month other two
methods yeah yeah exactly yeah and that
kind of brings us into the but actually
one of my examples when we're talking
about duck typing in julia but you know
previously we were using strings as
inputs to say hi for example but because
you know we're just doing string
interpolation under the hood with the
function say hi' we can interpolate a
numbers easily as another string and
then the function f you know we haven't
declared to work on any particular type
but it'll work now for any inputs for
which it's possible to multiply things
together so if we had a matrix a for
example and call F on a we're going to
get matrix matrix multiplication under
the hood because that's a well-defined
operation for the one of the well
defined methods for the the star
operator and then here's my original F
on high and however where where this
won't work where the functions I've
declared so far won't work is where
there aren't underlying methods to
support the types that I'm passing to
that function
so for example if I had a vector V which
just here has three elements if I pass V
to my function f which squares things
the reason that we get a method error
there is that there is no way to just
square a vector in Julia there's there's
no associated method with the idea of
multiplying a vector by another vector
because it's it's not clear what you
would want if you if you asked for that
it's not good if you want for example an
inner product or an outer product or
just element wise multiplication
and so Julia doesn't take a gas Julie
instead just gives you this message so
earlier I I called a couple functions
that had exclamation points at the end
and the reason for those exclamation
point is to denote whether or not a
function is a mutating function so a
mutating function is a function that
will alter some of the inputs that
you've passed to it and and by
convention in Julia where we have a
mutating function we'll follow the name
of that function by an exclamation point
but that is just a convention so you
could write your own function without
you know thinking out whether it's
mutating or non mutating and nobody's
forcing you to add the exclamation point
but if you're using a function that is
coming as part of into the base language
or you know part of the broader Julia
ecosystem you can normally trust it well
in the base language you can certainly
trust that if something has an
exclamation point is mutating if it
doesn't it's not and so an example of
mutating versus non mutating behavior
I'll show here with a sort function so
now we have a new vector V that has the
numbers 3 5 and 2 we call this sort
function on V we get this sorted vector
but if we look at the vector V itself
after calling sort it's it's unchanged
we didn't actually sort it if we had
instead called sort bang on V we get
that same output of a sorted vector but
now V itself is also the sorted vector
and so examples where I used mutating
functions prior to this notebook were
when I was calling pop bang and push
bang and I was calling those on arrays
that I was editing in place they're
adding an element or taking one away
questions on that so far okay
and so the idea of a higher order
function for those of you that may not
have heard that term before a higher
order function is just a function that
will take other functions as input
arguments and so a classic example of a
higher order function is the map
function where is the syntax for map
exactly the same in Python I maybe I
should show this in tax before I ask
that the syntax for map in julia is that
the first input to map will be a
function and then subsequent input
arguments to map will be collections
over which you will apply that function
element-wise and so if i call map on the
function f and then the vector that
contains the numbers one two and three
the return that i get is an array that
contains the the values of that array
one two and three with the function f
applied to each of them so that's what
we see here I'll just I'm squaring each
of the entries in that in that vector
and so is anybody here familiar with map
in Python is it exactly the same or yeah
okay and higher-order functions is one
place where we can actually make use of
lambda functions or anonymous functions
without binding variables to them to be
able to call them afterwards so if we
pass a lambda or an anonymous function
as the first input to map here it works
just as well as a function that we you
know might have declared outside of the
function call to map so there were just
cubing the entries of that vector one
two and three
now another higher-order function in in
Joya is the broadcast function which is
sort of a generalization of map so it's
able to handle certain use cases that
map cannot and for the purpose of this
tutorial we can we can just treat
broadcast for now like it is a clone of
map with a different name so if we were
to call broadcast on F and then this
back
here one two three we again are just
getting element wise squaring but one of
the things that's cool about broadcast
is that we can we can call broadcast
under the hood without explicitly saying
broadcast by simply adding a dot after
any function name in a function call so
if I say F dot so the vector 1 2 3 we
again see that element wise squaring and
kind of drive home that point if I had a
matrix say for example that has the
integers 1 2 9 from the upper left to
the lower right-hand corner if I call
the function f on a which is again just
our squaring function I'm going to get
the product of the matrix a times the
matrix a but if I call F dot on a I'm
actually broadcasting the square
function element-wise over the entries
of that that matrix a and one of the
things that is good about the dot syntax
is that it gives you what I think is a
more natural expression of the
mathematics that you might write down on
paper so rather than you know explicitly
needing just say broadcast writing out
some lambda function for example and
then you know applying that more you
know composed or complicated function to
some input array we can just add dots
associated each of our function calls
and and and get the same result also
broadcast will fuse your operations so
if we if we call broadcast in either of
these ways we don't get temporary
allocation of variables as we you know
perform one operation at a time we don't
need to you know for example call F on a
and store the result of that somewhere
temporarily before we can divide all the
elements by by the entries of a
any questions on this so far
the order of precedence will follow
whatever the like mathematical order of
precedence is and so and if I remember
correctly
normally addition and multiplication
reignover or sorry multiple division
reignover addition and subtraction yeah
yeah.what broadcast does that map cannot
do is that it can work with data
structures that don't have the same
dimensions so for example you could you
could add together with broadcast you
could add together a matrix and a number
or a matrix and a vector say for example
that you had a 2 by 2 matrix and a 2 by
2 vector you could yet you could add the
vector so that it was applied like
because if you would have added it to
each of the rows of the matrix rather
than yeah so another way to say that is
that if you add together two objects
with broadcast one of which has a
singleton dimension the other dimension
it that singleton dimension is expanded
to match the dimensionality of your
other object yeah sorry
thank you other questions okay so that
was our syntax tour notebook notebook 7
is where we just see how to use packages
in the Julie ecosystem and and 8 is
plotting which we can go through pretty
quickly and I definitely want to get
through notebook 9 so I think getting
through 7 through 9 will be really easy
with the time we have remaining and then
after that we can talk about whether you
want to see some linear algebra or talk
a little bit about the design paradigm
that sound good yeah okay cool so
notebook 7 all right so the Julie
ecosystem is these quickly growing we
have over 2,000 registered packages now
and one of the biggest design objectives
since the beginning of julia has been to
really provide first-class interfaces to
other languages and you know external
packages so that you know if you were
coming to Julia as the user of another
language like Python or are you wouldn't
have to worry about not having access to
some of your favorite functionality
other language as the Julia ecosystem
was growing and so for that reason we
have packages for example like you know
pi call and our call that will allow you
to call any
and any functions from within like the
bass Python or our languages also we'll
see in an upcoming notebook that you can
for example declare and compile code in
C from within Jupiter notebook or
generally from within and Giulia
environments and if you're interested in
seeing other you know available packages
that are out there we have all of our
our packages tracked on pkg Julia Lang
org as well as Giulia observer comm but
rather than trying to give you an
overview of the whole ecosystem the
point of this is really just to show you
how to to load and install an external
package and so how you would do that is
that you would start by saying that
you're using pkg wear pkg is our package
manager and so if I if I were to say I'm
using pkg and maybe I want to install a
package called example I would do that
like this and that should be pretty fast
state because I've already installed it
previously also examples a very small
package but these are the sorts of
notifications you would get as a package
installs if you are on julia box and
it's working right now all of our
packages are pre-installed so that you
wouldn't have to do this now when you
are working in your own local julia
installation
you only need to install a package once
for a given julia binary and thereafter
you can simply load the package without
installing it and how you put a load a
package is by saying that you're using
the example package for example in your
current environment so now I've loaded
example and the example package has its
source code stored on github at this
link under the example JL file and if
you were to go to that link you would
see that the source code includes this
this function declaration for Hello
which takes a string and then greets the
string and Eve passes an input argument
so now that I've run using example I
have to access to that hello function
and so I can print it some Adele lyrics
with it for example
another package that I like to demo
using is the colors package and so we
don't have to install today so we don't
have to run pkg ad all we have to do is
say that we're using colors and once
we've we started using the colors
package we have access to this function
called distinguishable colors which will
give us as many misspending
distinguishable colors as a gap for so
here we're getting a palette of a
hundred different colors one thing
that's kind of fun to do with this
palette is that here I'll add some extra
cells so we've seen this Rand command
before where the rand command if I pass
it the numbers three and three I'm going
to get this randomly populated 3x3
matrix that has floating point numbers
now if I want to randomly populate a
matrix with elements of other
collections I can specify collection as
the first input argument so I could say
for example populate my three by three
matrix with some number from the range 1
to 10 and now I'm getting a matrix of
integers now if I wanted to pass any
type of collections will still work so
if I if I pass the palette as my input
collection I get our randomly chequered
matrix and I just like this example
because I can keep running it and I
always get something different it's very
visual good to see the randomness better
so that's it for packages I have this
notebook on plotting next
yeah I know that often individual
packages from other ecosystems will get
wrapped separately so then there will be
other Giulia packages rather than using
PI call to call a Python function you
could call I'm trying to thing exactly
like we have I'll use in an upcoming
notebook there's a Conda package that
allows you to call numpy for example I
don't I don't know what the exact
coverage of the Python ecosystem is
within wrapping but yeah
so I'm not sure for example if you can
call pandas I kind of surprised if you
couldn't but but I'm not certain there's
okay there is okay right yeah PI call is
just an example the way that you would
interface with with a Python function
okay so I'm gonna read on this notebook
I'll run the whole thing at once the
plotting story in Giulia is still coming
along for the most part in Giulia we
mostly plot using other languages
plotting libraries you can even plot
with PI plot from within Giulia and the
plotting package little show today is
this one called plots or plots JL and
what's cool about plots is that it gives
you one common set of syntax from which
you can call multiple different backends
like pi plot or Unicode plots or gr plot
li j s and so thereby you can you can
write some code to generate a plot and
then thereafter you can decide you want
to use some other back-end and you only
have to change one line of code you
don't have to switch out syntax and so
to demo that what we will be plotting
today data that I data themed offline
where we have global temperatures for
several years between the 1860s and the
year 2000 global temperatures in degrees
Celsius and then the
numbers of pirates in the world at the
corresponding years in the next array
and then I'm calling here the GR
back-end you would have to go to the
plots al documentation to see which
backends are supported but here I'm
calling the gr back-end so we can start
plotting with gr and zoom out a little
so I can start creating a plot of my my
temperatures and my pirate populations
using this plot command up here where we
have my independence and my possibly
dependent data no here
yeah whatever is on the horizontal and
the vertical axes so we have this call
to plot first and then a call to scatter
bang and the reason that there's an
exclamation point there following
following the call to scatter and is
that this is actually a mutating call
where we're going to be mutating the
plot that we create with the plot call
so that we can create an overlay and
what you would see is that if we instead
were to delete this exclamation point
and run the code we would get two
separate plots one with a line plot and
one with a scatter plot so this is our
overlay one of the first things that we
can do is annotate our plot with these
other mutating functions X label Bay Y
label bang and title bang which are
giving us our our axes labels and our
title and here I I just like correlation
versus causation jokes so this is our
our pirate populations on global warming
effect one of the things that looks kind
of weird about this plot when you first
glance at it at it is that we see that
temperatures are going down as well as
pirate populations increasing and the
reason is that the third variable here
is time and then julia by default is
plotting whatever i have on the
horizontal axis an increasing order from
left to right but the data that we have
is actually populations are going down
over time as you as you might guess and
global temperatures have been rising and
so we actually kind of need to mirror
flip this plot in order to to look
forward in time rather than backwards
and we can do that with this x
foot bang command here so now we're
looking forward in time from left to
right and we can see that we we might do
better with more pirates now if you
wanted to use it a different back-end we
could call PI plot for example and then
with the same code just copied and
pasted we get a very similar looking
plot earlier we can also if i uncomment
this there's this other back-end called
you know code plots which give you a
pretty different interface but it looks
like the oh can you just do math there
yeah so that's what unicode plots would
look like I think it's more fun at the
the ruffle there the terminal rather to
use unicode plots but it looked I
realized this earlier it looks like
excellent bang doesn't work and unicode
plots for some reason so yeah and then
the point of the exercises that I have
at the bottom of this notebook we're
really just to show you how to do
subplots
I'm Julia and and what I'm doing here
I'll zoom back in is that I create four
plots that I've bound variables P 1 P 2
P 3 and P 4 and then I have this fifth
call to plot where I pass the names of
those plots of input arguments and I use
this layout keyword to specify my layout
and I could change that to in this case
a 4 by 1 or 1 by 4 or what have you
questions on plotting you okay all right
so this notebook is one that I'll run
all for two to get through more quickly
and this is the the benchmarking
notebook that I mentioned at the at the
beginning when I was doing my intro
slides and so the idea is that we're
going to look at different
implementations of again this some
function that adds together all the
elements of a vector and we're going to
look at implementations and see Python
and Julia where in particular we're
gonna start with just a handwritten
version of the son function C then we'll
optimize a little by using the the -
fast math flag then we'll look at a
built in I'm sorry a built in version of
the son function and python a built in
version from numpy and then our hand
written in python and then we'll look at
three different versions and Julia -
where we have the the built in and Julia
are handwritten and Julia and then our
hand written where we've thrown in some
single instruction multiple data now
again for the purpose of benchmarking
we're going to use a 10 million element
vector and so we generate that vector
with the ran command and we're sending
that to a vector called a and one of the
first things that we do after creating
this vector is just a sanity check to
make sure that our built in version of
some and julia is working the way we
might expect so if we call some on a we
have you know roughly 0.5 as our average
element here times 10 million and we're
getting about 5 million as our son so
that seems to be working as as you might
expect now for the purpose of
benchmarking in julia we could use this
at time macro if we wanted to we're at
time is just going to return the time
that it takes to run the piece of code
that that follows it and so one of the
issues with the at time macro is that
it's not it doesn't give you super
precise results because there might be
other things going on in your system you
just have you know one sampling point
for how fast something is so here we can
see some some wide variation and how
long some takes to run when we call at
time on different occasions and so a
better way to benchmark rather than
using this at time macro is to use
functions from within this benchmark
tools
cage and so what benchmark tools does is
that it will run many samples of a given
or it'll run a piece of code you're
trying to time many times and it will
gather as many as many samples there's
many statistics as it needs before sort
of converges along on some average I'm
not sure exactly what the heuristics for
that are but you'll see when you run
benchmark tools the number of samples it
takes well it will change every time
with with different pieces of code and
so I'll demo that first on our our hair
handwritten see implementation of some
so in this block of code and I didn't I
didn't draft this initial notebook I
know very little see but we have our C
code here enclosed within a string and
then down here is where we're actually
compiling our C code and ultimately
declaring within our our Giulia scope
this function called see some that's
going to be calling C code under the
hood and here you can see that we're
using this C call command to to grab the
C function that we actually generated
when we compiled in this line so there's
a little bit of black magic going on in
this call or in this function block but
but yeah if we call see some here we get
about five million more precisely if we
want to check that the output of C sum
is about the same of what we would get
from the Giulia built in sum we can use
this this set of curly equal signs which
under the hood is calling the is
approximate or is a procs function which
tells you if two numbers are the same
within some tolerance also we could you
know if we take the difference we can
see that there's a very small difference
between the two outputs so the idea is
that every time we we look at a
different imitation we'll do some sanity
checks and then we'll actually do the
benchmarking so when we benchmark this
implementation of see some here with the
app benchmark command we get some some
different statistics on the speed so we
see that there were 432 samples
again when we ran this and that the
minimum run time is reported as well as
the maximum run time and then to average
run times the meeting and the mean we
also get to see what sort of memory it
was used which isn't super interesting
here but might be more interesting if
you're benchmarking something else so
here our minimum run time is about
eleven point four milliseconds and so
we're going to grab that minimum of our
output times here and add it to this
dictionary called D that we're creating
in the line above what I've highlighted
there so that we can keep track of how
well each of the implementations do as
we go and one final thing in this
section is that we we have a plot here
of a histogram of the run times for for
this the implementations of some just
you can get a sense of you know why it
takes so many samples or you know what
kind of variance you might expect to see
in running a piece of code so here we
have no calls taking anywhere from maybe
eleven point three five to eleven point
six six or something milliseconds okay
so so now if we were to add the the fast
math flag to our C compilation we we can
declare a new function within our scope
called C some fast math and if we
benchmark that as we did above we see
that we went down from just over eleven
milliseconds to just over four
milliseconds so that was a pretty huge
optimization and then we can add this
best case runtime here again to this
output dictionary D so after looking at
our to C implementations well that's
unoxidized and one that is a bit
optimized we can move to the built in
version of some in Python which we can
bring in to our scope using the PI call
package which gives us this function PI
built in now if I call PI some we can
see that our sanity checks are working
and if we benchmark PI some here it's
taking over seven hundred milliseconds
to do that addition if we add that to
our our minimum or we add the minimum
there to our output dictionary we can
then move to our number
version of Python which is gonna be
considerably faster and what will pull
that in with with the Conda package and
then import some from our from the numpy
package and if we benchmark our numpy
version of some here or we're down to an
order of four milliseconds and yeah the
benchmark tools is fantastic and it
really you know decreases the error bars
on your measurements but but I would say
that you know so far the performance of
the the see with fast math that we saw
and you know numpy are essentially the
same like the I guess the the digits
after the decimal place will will change
considerably from from run to run even
when you're using something that takes
an average like benchmark tools so we
don't have enough information now to say
if you know numpy or the optimized see
is is doing better at this point but in
any case we'll add this numpy version to
our out for dictionary and then we can
move on to our handwritten python where
we now have our our python function
declared within again a string that's
not preceded by that pi keyword and
we're calling that some pi within our
current scope which we can benchmark
here and we're up to like about 900 or
950 milliseconds so then we can go to
Julia and in Julia we'll start by
looking at the the built in version of
some within julia and this at which
macro would tell us where we can
actually find a source code for for the
some function so it's going to be stored
in this file reduced mjl that line 645
and if you were to go there you would
see that the the built in version of
some with enjoy is actually written in
julia itself it's not implemented in a
lower level language like c and if we
benchmark the built in version of some
we're going to get to hear about 4.6 4.7
milliseconds so if we add that to our
output dictionary
we've got just two left one is the the
handwritten of julia which again looks
really similar to the you know
Python implementation of some we
benchmark that we're at about eleven
point four milliseconds and and finally
if we do exactly what we just did to
declare our Julia handwritten version of
some but we add this at sym D macro here
we now have a single instruction
multiple data version of the the same
function that we had above and
benchmarking this we can see that we
take it down from a little over eleven
to a little over four milliseconds so
this is having a comparable effect to
the the addition of the Fastnet flag
that we added to our C code so having
done all that we can can order the
performance of all the different runs in
that output dictionary we've been
storing results and I guess the the big
takeaways here one of the first is that
that Julia's handwritten without in the
optimization is is really similar to see
as handwritten without any optimization
similarly if you were to look at you
know Julia's built-in that's you know
converging on what we the sorts of
speeds that we're seeing for Python
numpy is with our optimized C code under
the hood and this version of our C
implementation that has the fast math
flag the the other thing here that's
really cool is that in enabled error
sorry and adding that that one command
the sim D macro to our handwritten
version of some in Giulia with just that
minor modification we were able to
really start to close this gap between
our simple handwritten implementation
and and and the built in here so really
I think the the built in and the one
with sim D are pretty comparable here
with the number of cores I have on my
machine but yeah so that's everything
for this notebook so far and we have
have about five minutes our people more
interested in seeing some of the linear
algebra stuff in the next five minutes
or talking about multi
dispatch if you like looking at linear
algebra surehand
okay so that color people and if you're
more injuries at a multiple dispatch
okay sorry
yeah so let's talk about that um so hope
and then if you want to stick around
look at linear algebra afterwards I all
still here but yeah well we'll try to
talk about what will dispatch quickly um
okay so before I look at the notebook at
first I guess sort of like high-level
overview or like the thing that made
multiple dispatch start to click for me
a little bit better okay yeah so so
mister you probably haven't heard welted
with this patch I hadn't heard of it
until I came to julia model dispatch is
sort of a you might think of it as a
generalization of single dispatch where
single dispatch is what's being used in
for example object-oriented programming
now our people here are familiar with
like the idea of object-oriented
programming or a lot of you okay so so
the idea of single dispatch in that
context is that let's say for example
that you have two classes one of dogs
and one of cats and and of course you
can you can instantiate an object of the
cat class or of the dog class and then
you have methods associated with each of
those classes so for example we might
have a say hi method associated with
either class and if we call the function
or the method say hi on a cat object we
might get him yow and if we call the say
hi method on the dog an object from the
dog class will get a bark and so what's
happening there is that when when we
make our function call and we call the
function say hi the method that we we
actually get at the end of the day
whether you know we get the method that
generates them you or the method that
generates a bark is determined by a
single input argument to our function
call to the function call to say hi and
and you know the syntax in ops you're
under programming is is such that you
know that that input
the status of your your object as being
a cat or a dog looks a little different
from your other inputs to your function
call because often you'll say like Fido
dot say hi but even though you're saying
Fido dot say hi Fido is still in inputs
to say hi and Fido is determining
whether you're getting you know your
bark or your your mouth at the end of
the day and so that single dispatch in
the sense that again there's just a
single input argument that's determining
which method you get and so multiple
dispatch is a generalization of single
dispatch where now instead every single
input to your function is going to
determine which function or rich method
associated with that function actually
gets dispatched at the end of the day so
I'll talk about that a little bit more
did you have a question yes insofar as I
understand polymorphism and C++ I think
that's fair but yeah you might want to
very well the fact check out the things
that I say okay so let's let's talk
through some examples of multiple
dispatch so I can start to show you what
I mean
and multiple dispatch is really a lot of
people think that Julie is fast because
it's just in time compiled instead of
interpreted but but really it's the
design paradigm that's making Julia fast
and so yeah so what we'll talk we'll
talk through this a bit more so starting
with some things that we've already seen
we've already seen that we can declare a
function for example a function f that
squares things and we don't have just
say you know what the function works on
and it will just sort of magically work
on things like strings and matrices and
numbers but it doesn't work on things
like vectors and again the reason is
that you know we have underlying methods
associated with you know numbers and
matrices and strings that tell us how we
would use the star operator and thereby
the exponentiation operator on those
those data types
under the hood and those methods that
already exist get called when we call F
but we don't have any method that tells
us what to do when we try to
exponentiate something that's a vector
and so we get that failure there now
alternatively rather than writing a
function and in sort of a generic way
and letting Giulia you know figure out
when the function works and when it
doesn't work on its own we could declare
functions in a way where we we specify
when we want the function to work and
where so for example we could declare a
function called foo so here here this is
a declaration for the function food that
takes two inputs X and Y and then I've
annotated the inputs x and y with a
double colon sign and then the types
that i want x and y to be so I'm saying
that X has to be a string and Y has to
be a string and and when I pass strings
x and y to foo I want the print out to
be my input x and y are both strings and
so if I call this function foo that I
just declared on the strings hello and
hi I get that printout that I you know
might be expecting and now if I were to
call foo on the integers 3 & 4 I get a
method error because I didn't declare
any function called food that will take
inputs that are that are both integers
so if I wanted to change that say say I
want to add a method that works on
integers 3 & 4 I can now declare foo
where i annotate x and y as being both
integers here so I'm saying X double
colon int y double colon int and now
when I pass two integers to foo I want
the printout to say my inputs x and y
are both integers and so I declare that
by running this cell if I call 3 fool on
3 & 4 I'm getting that input now that
says x and y are both integers but if I
go back and I call foo on hello and hi
we still get that output saying that x
and y are both strings and the reason is
that when I declared foo here I didn't
overwrite my first definition of foo I
didn't replace it with this new
definition I was able to just add an
extra definition to to a function that I
had already written and I can add you
know as many different definitions for
one function name as there are possible
of you know possibly infinite input
arguments to to a function so so if you
want to see I don't I guess maybe the
first thing to say here is that so so
really the the fundamental idea here is
that we have this distinction then
between generic functions and methods
where generic functions are really sort
of the abstract concepts that we have
tied to particular operations like we
have in our minds what it means to add
things together or to multiply things
together but then on a computer you know
we need concrete concrete ways of adding
together you know two different
floating-point numbers that's going to
different from how we add together two
different integers and so you know our
our specific implementations of how to
do any given operation are our methods
and and our functions are are more
abstract or more generic and that means
that we as users can just think about
these sort of generic function calls we
can just think about the fact that we
want to add things together and we don't
have to specify that we want you know
the type of addition that's meant for
integers or the type of addition that's
meant for one integer and one float but
the compiler at the time that it looks
at our code is going to realize that it
needs to dispatch you know a particular
method that's you know well tuned for
those inputs now if you want to see you
know what methods exist for a particular
function you can use this methods
function on a function name so if we
call methods on foo we can see that
there are two versions of this foo
sitting around which are the two that I
declared one for integers and one for
strings if you were to call methods on
the plus operator you would see that
there are 163 different ways to to add
things together in julia where this
includes you know adding float 32 is to
float 32 s and adding something that's a
missing very mrs. data point to another
missing and so forth so this is
basically just a huge comet oryx
problem here and now we have this other
function or macro rather called at which
which when we call out which on a piece
of code it's going to tell us which
function actually
dispatched for a given set of input
argument so if I call a twitch on foo of
three and for the version of food that
gets dispatched is the method that's
written for in 6464 if I call a twitch
on 3.0 plus 3.0 we can see that the
version of addition that's being used
there is the version that's written
specifically for float64 and now I
mentioned a little bit earlier but I
sort of glossed over it the fact that
julia has a type hierarchy where at the
very top there's the any abstract type
that encompasses all other types there
are other within that tree there are
other abstract types like like number
for example where the number type
encompasses you know all integers and
all floating points and all complex
numbers so we can also declare methods
for for other abstract types so I could
for example declare a version of this
function called foo that takes X and y
that are both numbers and then when x
and y are both members I want this
printout to be x and y are both numbers
so what happens now that I've declared
foo in this way is that if I were to
call foo on two floating point numbers I
I end up dispatching the the version
that was written for numbers because
floating points are subtypes of number
but we're always going to get the most I
guess specific method or the most well
tailored method that exists for a given
set of inputs so for example if I
declare foo without specifying what the
inputs are if I you know go to just foo
of x and y at this point if I were to
say foo on three and four I'll still get
the the integer version even though you
know this one is sort of
all-encompassing but now the
all-encompassing one that I've declared
there provides sort of a fallback method
for things I haven't thought of yet like
if I pass a vector now the only method
for which a vector will work as an input
is is that more all-encompassing generic
version of food that I wrote here
without any type annotation
so that's a lot of information other
questions that I read their questions
but hey yeah
there's not a way to delete a method
once you've added it you can easily
overwrite it and if you for example if
you accidentally overrode addition which
you could do then you would just have to
restart your ruffle or your notebook
that you were working in and then you
would have a clean slate for that but
yeah yes yeah that should be I'm really
bad at tab-completion I'd like don't
hold the keys the right about I think
you should do slash and then colon and
then if you start to write aprox
and then I swear other people do this
and it works
tap tap tap you should be able to just
hit tab and then it shouldn't give you
the curly braces
I can't I've failed at this in live
demos so many times and then often
there's someone else that knows Julia
from the audience then will come up and
like do the tab completion for me and
they give me the instructions are like
that's what I was doing but so yeah I'm
sorry um that's how it works sorry nope
:
does it work with it oh okay yep that's
that's why I broke it this time
I find a way to break it every time
thank you there's the curly braces and I
wonder I'm gonna see how if I do spy oh
I wanted to do smiley cat and I got just
a smile but yeah anyways that's how you
talk complete
other questions yeah so I'm just still
kind of curious about the speed sorry
and what I said earlier or what I meant
to say earlier was it is just in time
compiled but I mean that's not the
reason that that alone wouldn't make a
language fat it fast if it were not well
designed but okay so given that it does
answer okay good other questions okay
does anyone want to look at linear
algebra or stick around or you want to
it's it's late in their time yeah okay
well then we're done thank you so much
for coming
[Applause]